Oh
with interactive posts you can add a
call to action button to shares from
your app picture a button on your post
that reads watch listen or join these
buttons make your posts stand out and
consequently interactive posts get a
significantly higher click-through rate
as compared to a normal person
interactive posts can also trigger
notifications in the Google bar across
Google properties this means that your
apps notification will be seen
regardless of whether the user is on
Google Maps Google search YouTube and of
course Google+ we also help you make
your shares more targeted using our API
so you can pre-fill the text and you can
also pre-select up to ten recipients
when friends either post
they'll be presented with a button
asking them to vote watch a trailer
RSVP subscribe or whatever it is that
correlates to the action you want
recipients to take there are over a
hundred buttons to choose from and we
have translated them all for you when
recipients click the call to action
button it deep links them to a specific
place in your website or in your iOS or
Android app not only does the deep link
take users right into your app but it
also drives app installs because if the
user doesn't already have your app
they'll be prompted to install it
interactive posts are a great way to
increase engagement with the content
that your users are sharing with their
friends check out our developer Docs for
more about interactive posts